what do you call a man who doesn't
respect your privacy Mark Zuckerberg
Mark Zuckerberg has a ball of money the
size of the Moon and the personality of
a bowl of oatmeal he's like Pinocchio if
Pinocchio's wish was to be a real lizard
he's like data from Star Trek if data
got a computer chip that made him less
human and speaking of data you can tell
Mark Zuckerberg would make a good friend
because he listens to everything you say
when Mark Zuckerberg travels he brings
three Chargers one for his laptop one
for his cell phone and one for himself
when he sees a psychiatrist it's called
tech support I heard that he once got
into a fight with Jeffrey Epstein
Hollywood made a movie out of it the
movie was called Alien versus Predator
I do not like Mark Zuckerberg now why
don't I like this guy you might think
it's because he's a billionaire tech
nerd but Elon Musk is also a billionaire
tech nerd and I like Elon Musk so what's
the difference between Elon Musk and
Mark Zuckerberg well one wants to go to
outer space to colonize Mars the other
Came From Outer Space to colonize Earth
I do not like the one who came from
outer space to colonize Earth and yet
there's something I like about him
there's something I really like about
him there's something I like about him
so much that I can say I love Mark
Zuckerberg even though I can't stand him
and his haircut looks like it came with
30 free hours of America online
what do I like about Mark Zuckerberg
well speaking only for myself here I
like people who image God in various
ways people who reflect God in various
ways and I like them even more when
they're Imaging God as they're talking
about being created in the image of God
so Lex Friedman asks Mark Zuckerberg a
question
big ridiculous question what do you
think is the meaning of life
I think that well there are probably a
couple of different ways that that I
would go at this but I think it gets
back to this last question that we
talked about about The Duality between
you have
the people around you who you care the
most about and then there's like this
bigger thing that maybe you're building
Lex asks him about the meaning of life
and Mark focuses on two things
relationships with other people and
Building Things
I think Mark may be on to something
and I think that in my own life I mean I
I sort of think about this tension but
let's look at I started this whole
company in my life's work is around
human connection so
I think it's intellectually probably
the thing that I go to First is just
that human connection is the meaning
Mark thinks that we don't value human
connection enough
and I mean I think that it's a thing
that our
Society probably
systematically undervalues I mean I just
remember you know when I was growing up
and in in school it's like do your
homework and then go play with your
friends after and it's like no well what
if what if playing with your friends is
the point as much as we don't like
Facebook mining our data and by our data
I mean your data I got out of that hell
hole years ago as much as we don't like
Facebook selling our data to the highest
bidders namely companies that will use
the data to manipulate us as much as we
don't like the censorship and the bias
and the manipulation of the platform
Mark Zuckerberg's intention for Facebook
and for the metaverses building seems to
be to create places where people from
around the world can interact he wants
to use the internet to increase human
connection he wants to bring people
closer together the endless chunks of
money he makes while doing it are just a
perk so human connection is part of the
meaning of life but the other part is
building something
there's a a rabbi who I've studied with
who who kind of gave me this we were
talking through Genesis and the the
Bible and the Torah and
and they're basically walking through
it's like okay you go through the the
seven days of of creation and
and
it's basically it's like why does the
bible start there
right it's like I could have started
anywhere right in terms of like how to
live
the Bible could have started with a list
of rules but it started with God
creating
why is that basically it starts with
talking about how God created people in
his her image
but the Bible starts by talking about
how God created everything
so I actually think that there's like
a compelling argument that I think I've
always just found meaningful and
inspiring that a lot of the point of
what sort of religion
has been telling us that we should do
is to create
and build things
Genesis 1 in a nutshell God creates God
creates God creates God creates God
creates God creates and then God creates
human beings male and female and he says
that men and women are created in His
image so the immediate context of God
saying that human beings are created in
His image is God creating
I really like watching people fumble
their way to an important point in my
video Norm Macdonald the image of God we
took a close look at Genesis 1 verses 26
through 28 and we saw that in the verses
that say Man was created in the image of
God what it means to be created in the
image of God has something to do with
relationships and the verses that say
Man was created in the image of God
there's man's relationship with God
there's man's relationship with other
human beings and there's man's
relationship with the natural world and
Man was created to image the Eternal God
in all three of these relationships
that's the meaning of image of God you
get from Genesis 1
26-28 but as our new friend Mark pointed
out the context of that passage is God
creating a universe so God creates a
place for people to have relationships
and he says that men and women are
created in his image
what does Mark Zuckerberg who's created
in the image of God do with his life
so these things are not necessarily at
odds I mean I think like I mean that's
and I think probably to some degree
you'd expect me to say something like
this because I've dedicated my life to
creating things that help people connect
he creates digital worlds for human
relationships talk about Imaging God
now unfortunately the interview ends
right after this but we can think
through this a bit more
Mark Zuckerberg and Co created Facebook
which is a kind of world where people
interact but now they're creating the
metaverse which is an actual virtual
universe so he creates a universe for
people to build connections and what do
people do with the universe they've been
given
they instantly start horribly abusing
each other a British woman who recently
decided to join the zuckerverse says
that she was virtually gang raped within
seconds of joining her Avatar was gang
raped virtually
think about this
you build a universe you want to bring
people closer together
and people use the universe you built
for gang rape so what do you do
you make some rules you put together a
trust and safety team to enforce the
rules but as soon as you start making
and enforcing rules everyone starts
complaining because wherever you draw
the line on any difficult issue there
are going to be people on one side of
the line who say you're being too strict
and there are going to be people on the
other side of the line who say you're
not being strict enough
there's a lot of push there's things
like you've got to do more there's
clearly a lot more bad content that that
people aren't reporting or that you're
not getting to and you need to get more
effective at that and I was pretty
sympathetic to that but then I think at
some point along the way there started
to be almost equal issues on both sides
of okay actually you're kind of taking
down too much stuff right or or some of
the stuff is is borderline and and it
wasn't really bothering anyone and then
report it so is that is that really an
issue that you need to take down whereas
we still we still have the critique on
the other side too where a lot of people
think we're not doing enough as we built
the technical capacity I think it
becomes more philosophically interesting
almost where you want to be on the line
the challenge with free speech is that
everyone agrees that there is a line
where if you're actually about to do
physical harm to people there should be
restrictions the thing that everyone
agrees disagrees on is what is the
definition of real harm the result is
that everyone is angry and who do we get
angry at
the one who built the platform or the
metaverse or the universe
and we don't just get angry about the
rules we get angry because the people
who enforce the rules are quite
frequently total scumbags the reason I
left Facebook wasn't that I had a
problem with the rules I had a problem
with the people who were paid to enforce
the rules because they didn't seem to
care about the rules at all they just
seemed to ban a person for saying
something they didn't like so someone
would send me a death threat I would
take a screenshot of the death threat
and I would post it and say hey everyone
look what this guy just said he said
he's going to kill me I was trying to
shame the person
and Facebook would suspend me for hate
speech
I once got suspended for posting a
famous picture of a man who refused to
salute Hitler I posted the picture with
a circle around the guy who refused to
salute Hitler and a caption that said be
this guy be the sort of person who
wouldn't salute an evil person even if
everyone around you was saluting the
evil person
Facebook banned the picture as hate
speech kind of ironic it's like Facebook
was saying how dare you tell people not
to submit to an evil and corrupt
Authority this happened over and over
and over again until I got sick of the
platform and left now it wasn't Mark
Zuckerberg who was Banning my posts and
repeatedly suspending me it was either
morally depraved or irretrievably stupid
content moderators who were suspending
me but I had no idea who was Banning
content that should never be banned so
who did I come to despise you guessed it
the face of Facebook Mark Zuckerberg
he's the one who set up the massively
defective system so he's the one I
didn't like I now have no desire to be
on Facebook and no desire to enter the
metaverse in fact I can only think of
one reason to enter the metaverse
you know what we should do
we should all join the Matrix I mean the
metaverse then
we should wait a while
we should wait until we've all been
plugged into it for a long time we
should wait until the metaverse is
reality to us and then once the
metaverse is reality to us we'll start a
community of people who don't believe
that Mark Zuckerberg even exists will
make fun of anyone who believes in Mark
Zuckerberg
that'll be the ultimate slap in his
cyborg face
so I like Mark Zuckerberg for the ways
he images God but a lot of people
including myself don't like him because
of some of the decisions he's made and
some of the ways people are treated in
the worlds he's created
this hostility towards Mark Zuckerberg
leads to an intriguing question
why do you think so many people dislike
you
some even hate you
and how do you regain their trust and
support given everything you just said
we know why people don't like Mark
Zuckerberg so the important question is
what can mark do to regain people's
trust
Mark has no clue I can only speak for
myself here but I can tell you all
exactly what Mark Zuckerberg could do to
regain my trust Mark is building the
metaverse
many people are going to use the
metaverse to abuse and degrade each
other so rules will need to be made
rules will need to be enforced but the
people who are paid to make and enforce
these rules will also use their
positions of power to abuse and degrade
users and there will be absolutely
nothing that users can do about it same
as Facebook same as Twitter same as
YouTube
users will feel completely helpless as
the people who are given power over them
use that power to abuse them
and these same users who feel helpless
will think about Mark Zuckerberg and his
billions of dollars and he'll seem like
he's incredibly distant so distant that
it's like he's in another world
if Mark Zuckerberg wanted to regain my
trust
he would have to enter the metaverse not
as Mark Zuckerberg with all his
privileges but as a normal user
the people who run the metaverse the
people who enforce the rules the other
users they couldn't know that he was
Mark Zuckerberg
he'd have to live like any other person
in the metaverse
then he'd have to expose the problems in
the metaverse from within the metaverse
he'd have to expose the horrible
behavior of other users and especially
of the people who enforce the rules
he'd have to be attacked and beaten by
other users who are angry at him for
shining a light on their behavior he'd
have to be repeatedly suspended by the
people who enforce the rules because
they don't like what he's saying
he'd have to be horribly mistreated
while doing absolutely nothing wrong
until the people who enforce the rules
terminate his account
that's what he'd have to do to regain my
trust
whatever else Mark Zuckerberg did after
that
I would at least know
that he understands what it's like to be
in the world he's created
imagine a creator
who did that
[Music]